Donnez moi les noms des kamikazes.
Tout le monde est déjà à l’intérieur.
A plus papa.
Une explosion a frappé la ville aujourd'hui.
20 000 Pounds pour les noms des  kamikazes.
C'est pas comme ça que ça marche ici
Bonjour.
Monsieur Hennessy, il est là, encore.
Ça fait 5 jours d’affilé. Qu'est ce qu'il veut?
Sa fille a été tué dans une attaque à la bombe.
Monsieur Hennessy s'il vous plait, découvrez les noms des kamikazes.
Je travail pour le gouvernement, pas les terroristes.
Vous avez travaillé pour eux.
Je ne sais pas qui sont ces  kamikazes.
Je ne vous crois pas.
C'est lui.
Vous allez me donner les noms des  kamikazes.
Il est entraîné.
Peut être les forces spéciales.
STOP! Elle est prête à exploser!
Il veut juste vous faire savoir qu'il peut vous avoir.
Qu'est ce qui ce passe?
Il pense que je sais qui à exploser sa fille?
Le sais tu?
La moitié de la ville le cherche.
C'est un vieil homme qui tourne en rond autour de beaucoup d'entre nous.
Ouvre le.
Vous n'avez pas idée avec qui vous faites affaires.
Si, je le sais.
Le savez- vous?